[reporter, in English] Her case
is grabbing headlines across the nation.
People want to know,
where is Vanessa Guillén?
[woman 1] Where's my sister?
They know where she is.
I want them to speak up.
This was not one of those cases
the military could sweep under the rug.
[woman 1] Vanessa's always been
the bravest of all of us.
Something was wrong with her the few months
after she was stationed at Fort Hood.
[woman 2] Not being able to sleep,
losing weight.
She would tell me
that things weren't what they seemed.
[in Spanish] She said,
"I have been harassed by a superior."
Over at Fort Hood, it's nothing more
than a place of corruption and evil.
[woman 2, in English]
I called the staff sergeant.
He's like, "We don't know anything
about her."
"You guys don't have cameras, nothing?"
And they were like, "No."
[woman 3] The military
did not give a damn.
Fort Hood seems to cultivate
the worst of the worst.
[man] A lot of missing soldiers,
a lot of dead soldiers.
A lot of bad there.
[woman 4] She's in the Army.
She's supposed to be safe there.
[in Spanish] I texted. No answer.
"How come?"
"These animals won't look for my child.
I have to look for my daughter myself."
[man in English] The Guillén family
weren't gonna stay quiet.
[woman 4] The Hispanic culture
is a sleeping giant,
and the Guillén family woke it up.
- [protester] What do we want?
- [crowd] Justice!
[woman 2] People using my sister
as a resemblance of themselves.
[woman 5] #IAmVanessaGuillén.
I remember saying, "She is us."
[woman 1] It kept growing and growing.
- [protester] What do we want?
- [crowd] Justice!
What's her name?
[crowd] Vanessa!
[woman 1] Loud and proud! What do we want?
[woman 7] Sexual assault scandals
are the new norm for the military.
Clearly an epidemic.
[woman 1] We had no other choice
but to go and fight for a legislation
under my sister's name.
[man] The military counts on survivors
and their families staying quiet,
and they miscalculated dramatically.
[woman 2] If we got Congress to listen,
then we can get Congress to pass the bill.
This is our last chance.
They do not support
the full Vanessa Guillén Act.
We have to really push on them.
This is not a Republican-Democratic issue!
This is not a race issue!
This is a human issue,
so it should be everyone's issue!
[dramatic music swells]